Hey, Ian, so it's not a big deal, but
you know how we want Sunshine to
just be the best it can be and
we've been working really hard to
personalize it and polish it up?
The thing is, it just doesn't
really make me feel amazing.
>> I don't know, when I get a weather
notification from Sunshine,
it really makes me feel like Sunshine's
helping me see into the future.
Right, but that's not really taking it
far enough because think of it with like
notifications.
Sometimes, a daily notification
isn't really enough, but
then other times you've just have this
same sunny, gorgeous weather every day.
>> Yeah, good times.
>> Right, so I was talking to Dan,
and I have some changes that I want to
make that I think will be really useful.
Something that's a little more now,
and a little less into the future.
>> Okay, you do that.
Dan wanted to show me this crazy
redesign of Sunshine he's working on, so
I'm going to go down there now,
and then go enjoy the sun.
>> [SOUND]